now we're hearing that ukraine's
president zielinski is trying to arrange
a sit-down with vladimir putin but a
major issue is time and place
here with some insight on that
christopher cox co-founder of consulting
group global partners llc
so chris we're hearing reports they're
going to surround the capital they've
already pushed saboteurs inside
at some point a negotiation has to take
place what are you hearing from
intelligence sources about what that
negotiation is looking like
well you're absolutely right jesse it's
great to be on with you tonight uh what
i'm hearing from my european sources are
that uh the zielinski group and the
putin group they've been talking and
they've been trying to come up with a
place and a time to meet and discuss now
of course
the putin is wants to gain as much
leverage as he can and that's why i
think we're seeing an increase in
military activity around kiev tonight
that he wants to increase his leverage
with a big breakthrough around kiev
surround president zielinski and really
force a negotiated settlement on him i
think that's putin's plan and i think
tonight we'll see the will of the
ukrainian people they will fight back
hard and if they repel that attack that
will elevate
president zielenski and his negotiating
position and what i've been hearing is
is that the negotiations have come down
to where these two groups should meet uh
president putin of course has suggested
minsk which is essentially a home game
for the russians and uh president
zielinski would prefer somewhere else
warsaw jerusalem has been suggested as
well that would be more of a home game
for him i know the israeli ambassador
has been involved in terms of helping
with these negotiations so i think that
we're going to find out very quickly how
this is going to end does putin really
want an off-ramp or is he really
absolutely crazy and wants to be a czar
of russia and impose a military solution
on ukraine
so zilenski has to decide he can either
go down fighting or he could broker some
sort of settlement do you think the
zielinski
team trusts putin if he leaves the
country
and goes to a summit outside of ukraine
is there a chance he might not come back
and
what kind of leverage does he have once
he leaves the capitol
absolutely i think that's very much a
fear of his as we've seen uh minsk in
belarus is not a place that's been safe
uh for people who oppose putin to go
even if you fly over uh belarus they've
been known to force down airplanes and
take civilians who oppose putin off
those aircraft so zielinski is very
right to fear going to minsk or to not
want to go to minsk and i think that
it's a much better idea for him to have
a negotiation elsewhere
and i think quite frankly this will come
down to the ukrainian people they are a
strong people we have seen how
ukrainians have actually blown
themselves up to destroy bridges to
prevent the russian advance if that will
persist through tonight and the days
ahead putin will be in for a very
difficult fight already the russians
have lost over 28 servicemen to put that
in context the united states lost 4 400
servicemen over the entire span of the
war in iraq putin cannot withstand body
bags coming home to moscow that will
weaken him domestically and will
significantly help zielinski all right
thank you so much for that great insight
chris cox we appreciate it
thank you jesse hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else